332 o lado pessoal do andar que seja
muito bem vindo já mais de um vídeo e o
estrago já que é isso estragos mas sim a
cabelo e ainda pensar para este desafio
é só o calor
[Música]
o pessoal é capaz de encontrar um gangue
do público fica um banho e amarildo
[Música]
agora aqui que foi um milagre que tem o
edinho estilac tottenham e sapatos ao
tabuleiro grande disputam em le grand
o jovem encontrava-se uma enguia o
shopping vai agora buscar o milho meu
tempo é cansado a gente andou pra
[ __ ]
a agenda do fazer a maratona para a tv
américa
achei boa a porto alegre em gel como o
do diálogo com brinde ela tinha um de
beringel
[Música]
lupi vai buscar para estragar a natureza
vamos buscar o estúdio já tem aqui o
milho vamos agora abrir e preparar as
coisas que vamos produzir fio a
enfrentar domingo tem que ficar aqui
preso após por um lápis ou pincel do
funcionado em casa
[Música]
o papel que eu sei que tanto eu preciso
estar bem perdido agora vou prender o
cabelo só para não acontecer o que
aconteceu aquela juíza o impacto da
frança
[Música]
o
gil
é
[Música]